a raunchy comedy about a teacher who's
an [ __ ] that could be really good bad
teacher so the premise of bad teachers
Cameron Diaz is a bad teacher she
doesn't care about her job she doesn't
care about the students she just shows
and movies and she's like that is good
and so throughout the movie Cameron Diaz
his character schemes ways to get money
so she can get a tit job it's actually
the premise all right so when I saw the
trailer for this movie I was like this
is awesome
because I've always wanted to know the
teachers perspective I always knew that
I did not want to be anywhere near
school when I was in school but I have
to believe that teachers are the same
way they don't want to be there either
which makes sense because no one really
elects to be a teacher if you ask
someone what do you want to be and they
say I want to be a teacher
that's a socially acceptable way of
pretty much saying I have no clue what I
want to be now you know so I wanted to
see a really cool representation of the
behind the curtains of a teacher's life
even if it is a little exaggerated and
was it awesome hmm I mean had all the
potential in the world but as I always
say there's a difference between
potential and reality I had a good cast
I mean Cameron Diaz was really good in
her character you can just tell she
liked playing the I don't give a [ __ ]
attitude teacher she did it really well
too this is scenes where she's talking
with her friend from the office who
pretty much plays the chick from the
office and they're talking she's eating
her food then she looks over and just
starts taking her friends food and
eating that too and you just wonder
you're like is that ad-lib it could be
it just looks like she's really into
that character and anyone could really
have fun with that kind of character
granted she's not a good person in fact
she's quite an [ __ ] but that's okay
with me because I watch It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia and everyone and
that shows an [ __ ] too Timberlake
plays the rich teacher that she's trying
to date it was alright in the role but
anyone could have played that role it
could have been like James Franco I
wouldn't have known the difference that
one dude from Forgetting Sarah Marshall
Zinn it eats like an average guy he's
really funny he keeps chasing Cameron
Diaz and I'm like dude why are you doing
that she said don't do that he looked
really desperate I felt like bad form is
better chicks out there like prostitutes
speaking of which the carwash scene that
was cool but the best character in the
entire movie is that one chick that I
always say looks like the [ __ ] Alexis
Arquette she was hilarious she was like
batshit crazy and she plays batshit
crazy really well hilarious psychos
people that's what it's all about and
odds are you know one person who's going
to end up like that anyway you know the
really sunshiny academic freak in your
class or your workplace yeah that's her
best character in the entire movie she
was awesome the problem with this movie
is the script because even though you
have a promising prospect that could be
really awesome when the movies written
by the guys who wrote year one do I even
need to add to the sentence really I
mean just like I said in grown-ups and I
still hold to it every scene was like an
isolated comedic scene but in every one
of these scenes is like the scene would
have been more funny if it had one
sentence that tied the whole thing
together just that one comedic sentence
to just put it over the top or you're
like that was hilarious it's almost like
the joke sets up and then it just ends
it goes to the next scene it's like an
edited rated R movie makes no sense the
movies only like 90 minutes long it
feels like a full two hours because like
a Michael Bay movie ends like five times
so in the end good premise one hilarious
character one likeable character and one
actress chick who really had fun doing
the role and she was really good at it
and a script I had shitty situational
humor and a couple of funny lines but
wasn't as funny as it should have been I
will say it would be alright if you're
drunk
yeah now as a party I'm just saying if
you go into this movie hammered you
won't notice how the plot and the scenes
in the script doesn't fit together well
so it's like medicinal drinking at that
point consult your doctor so in high
school what were you were you like a
nerd were you a jock were you popular
we're not did you wear all black and
[ __ ] I was a nerd don't say it right now
I wore videogame t-shirts like black
pants couldn't talk to girls for [ __ ] I
was pretty funny but had no people
skills whatsoever comment below I want
to know the people I draw to my channel
did you punch out Biff in the parking
lot did you notice that the hot chicks
in high school got fat after high school
that's always awesome
anything like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you